[音楽]
goo
ねーむーん皆さんおはようごはんまず本当に多分30分ぐらいしか寝てないです皆さん
ふりかけご存知でしょうか
あの普通にご飯食べてもこうなんかレッグご飯で士郎ご飯
白が苦手でしょってむしろ5万苦手な人って結構多いと思うんですけどもまぁ
とりあえず前の朝は皆さんと朝ごはん食べた方がいいですよだめです取りますで
朝ごはんです
がもうローゼンご飯を食べるんだったら美味しく食べたじゃないですかねしろこの
おいしく食べる方法としては味付けがあるわけでございますでその白ご飯の味付けの
代表格として
作りかけがありますよね
今回ドンキホーテに売ってる滑らぬふり鍵をゲットしていきます
多くね地味にあった州は僕は知ってるんですよ
ふりかけて
美味しいですや本当にあのなんか別に僕白が乗っていますがむしろスローは月ですの
最近は食べませんけどふりかけて美味しくないのないじゃないですか
子なんですよと思う付けたら100%美味しいですもうなぁあっもう
取り卵そぼろの影が100番手で美味しいレバはカチッとふりかけだってかけたら絶対
欲しいでしょハズレがない
この酒造赤ぶどう絶対壊れてほしいというわけで僕の経験ずをふりかけて実はとっても
美味しいんですよそこで私は思った全部ま設定
食ったら100%おいしいてっつっ子いっぱいっていうわけで熱湯風呂出なかっ
残念水入ってる
あー noon アフリカ研究めぇ愉快 o 2 o 3 b 3組さーああああっ
のりたまチャージドラッグ doodle
ふりかけとりたはコソボラーメです
どちらにごま白イベ的だった冊昭ふりかけや金リングのふりかけです
ニンニクふりかけポン酢ふりかけのり弁の音下に祝宴ずです
絶版名著でふりかけ番目調布に彼にポリ卵そぼろんなんか
同じのあったってが一瞬ケアでふりかけ競ったよい子じゃん
辛子明太子ぷちっとマグ
誰だよいやこれでもやめとこうかなーこれがふりかけじゃないなぁがごはんですよと
プチッとマグロアボカドロッドしてるんですよねドロッとしてるとサーキットいけない
かそのドロッとしてるコイツ等にふりかけ加工前ちゃうねあんたたちはちょっと失格と
いうことでねほんとにサラサラと書けるものだけをふりかけていう地域でやっていき
ましょう
なんかここだけ真面目なんだよな野菜ふりかけ吊り目さん所
無理魂何処所ああ豚しょうが焼きがツアー
次に草がのふりかけうわぁやバッグか
あの焼き肉の食べのふりかけ相手と陸路のフリークアウ日
味を競った下記のは古い賢いにょありすぎた梅殺すぞ
自分しそわかめ縁マーズすぎなぁいい中パー鶏そぼろ鶏そぼろって言うんだよねあ入れ
ていって最後
納豆ふりかけで師さんとも仲いいのかうわーんいたいうわけで完成しました
タイトルで完成してしまいましたがなんかすごいですねもう味の件だが全くつかない
もう何謝礼南女入れたんだろうただどれも祭りにおいしいっていうのはぼく知ってるん
で全部混ぜて果たしてまずは美味しいのか美味しくないのかとして何味に何度か行って
いいかと思いますしっかりまずはちゃんと全部混ぜなきゃいけないんでまずでいき
ましょう
まあもう完璧に混ざっていると思いますできましたこれがすべてのふりかけを混ぜた
最強のふりかけだと思いますさあ果たして何味でなるのでしょうか
5直てきます
[音楽]
はいでは早速いただきたいと思いますバズッ貶さっていうのはどうしてもあると思うん
でそこにかけるふりかけがいかにおいしくできるか結構大事だと思うんですよねちゃ
かけていきましょう
これかける飲む酢たん問わず整体ちょっと多めにかけますねああ
すごいなんかもうほんとにいろんな
破片がつながってますねあとは美味しいかどうかでございます後味だな果たして
フリック削れるの混ぜると何味になるのでしょうかいただきま
匂いが
[音楽]
与座表現できませんなんだこれ
ni
埋まるん
me
うううう
uh
me
あっはぁ
味のバラツキが酷いなんで別に食べにくいわけではないんですよ普通に美味しいと思う
んですけどなにこれで花燃ゆは残念もしょっぱいして甘いしかないし
願いし酸っぱいしいろんな味があったら分かりませんもう風味もバラバラだから何な何
以上に具だくさんのカレーみたいな
入居します触れ書けば
混ぜたため売掛はまず3度目だぞ